Bon...
Je vous fais un rapide topo.
Vous inquiétez pas, ce sera pas long.
Le suspect a la trentaine...
De type caucasien...
Mesurant environ 1m80.
La dernière fois qu'il a été repéré, c'était hier...
Entre 20 heure et 22 heure...
Au croisement de la 42ème et de Park Avenue.
Et on suppose qu'il s'est échappé par là.
Nous avons retrouvé, sur les lieux du crime...
Bon, j'ai l'impression que la petite nouvelle aurait envie de partager quelque chose avec tout le monde...
Alors allez-y De Luca, on vous écoute.
Ah non. Pardon.
Mais en fait, j'ai pas bien compris par où il est passé.
Et ben, par là.
Par la porte.
Ah c'est une porte...
D'accord.
Vous ne distinguez pas très clairement une porte et un immeuble là ?
Si, si.
Evidemment.
Maintenant que vous le dites c'est très clairement une porte.
Quelque chose me dit que vous pensez pouvoir mieux faire De Luca.
Non, vraiment pas.
Allez-y.
Montrez nous ce que vous avez.
Non, mais disons que moi...
Le croisement 42ème et...
Park Avenue, j'aurais fait un truc comme ça...
Je suis pas une pro en dessin mais j'ai prit quelques cours...
Quand j'étais gamine...
Faites voir.
Mouais.
Ça vous semble plus clair que le dessin que j'ai fait avant ?
Non, non.
C'est mal fait.
C'est bien ce qu'il me semblait.
Donc, je disais...
C'est le croisement entre la 42ème et Park Avenue ça ?
Oui.
Ça me fait bizarre parce que me tati habitait là...
Et j'allais en vacances chez elle quand j'étais petit quoi.
On dirait une photo en fait, c'est ça qui est fou !
C'est que on ne peut pas ne pas reconnaître le truc quoi.
C'est Google Maps, c'est incroya...
Dégagez Flambert !
De Luca vous retournez à votre place.
Et je vous préviens, je vous ai à l'oeil hein !
Alors vous arrêtez tout de suite cette petite provocation.
Ou alors je vous colle 6 mois aux archives, c'est clair ?
Oui, oui, c'est très clair.
Je reprends.
Donc, voici ce qu'on a retrouvé sur les lieux du crime.
Un duvet...
Mais attention...
C'est là que ça devient intéressant.
Une...
Tronçonneuse !
Vous voulez vous la jouer comme ça De Luca ?
Vous avez du cran.
J'aime bien.
Non, mais en fait je voulais juste vous montrez que j'étais volontaire et...
Ok, très bien !
Voyons voir si...
Avec ses deux lettres là...
Vous seriez capable de deviner...
De quel délit il s'agit.
Alors ça !
Et là ?
Je vous écoute maintenant.
Allez !
Euh...
Un R.
Ok.
Agression sur personne dépositaire de l'autorité publique ?
C'est facile.
C'est la guerre que vous voulez De Luca ? C'est ça ?
C'est la guerre que vous voulez ?
Regardez, si vous vous mettez à ma place, je vous jure que c'est plus simple en fait.
Vous voulez prendre ma place ?
Mais pas du tout, pas du tout, c'est pas ce que je voulais dire.
C'est que, si vous prenez du recul...
C'est hyper clair.
Là.
Un... Q ?
Non.
Un H.
Un P.
Non.
Bon ben... un E.
Non plus, non.
Un U !
Un O, vous avez dit un O là ?
Un D.
Un O ?
Bon...
Ecoutez, ce mot n'existe pas !
Vous êtes clairement en train de l'inventer là !
J'ai l'impression que vous avez vraiment envie de passer 6 mois aux archives !
Mais je vous jure que c'est un mot qui existe !
C'est un vrai mot.
Est-ce que quelqu'un connait ce mot ?
Non, non, non.
Non, non.
Elle invente hein.
C'est bien ce qu'il me semblait.
Ah bah c'est "vol".
Oui, c'est ça ! C'est ça !
Dégagez Flambert !
Vous savez quoi ?
On va régler ça une bonne fois pour toute.
Au mime !
On fait des équipes !
Qui est avec moi ?
Moi... Moi je veux bien si vous voulez.
Ok De Luca.
Mais je vous préviens...
Vous arrêtez avec vous petites embrouilles.
Si je perds...
C'est toute la brigade qui passe 6 mois aux archives !
C'est clair ?
Votre sort est désormais entre les mains de De Luca.
C'est parti !
Oh on comprend rien !
Passez, on a pas le temps !
Qu'est ce que ça veut dire ?
Quoi ?
Si vous savez pas ce que c'est ne le faites pas !
La ceinture...
Passez ! Passez ! Allez !
Quoi ?
On comprend rien.
Gangnam Style ?
Gangnam Style avec un flingue ?
Non !
Bon, je vois p...
Mais qu'est ce que vous venez de faire De Luca ?!
Mais justement, c'était quoi ça ?!
C'est un meurtre ça !
Splendide.
Merci.
Bravo commissaire.
Par contre y a pas droit aux accessoires normalement.